you got to get inside the holy grail of
chipmakers and you saw a particular chip
getting made I did you know we don't we
don't really think about especially
server chips which is which is what we
followed in this story as being an
important part of our lives but it's a
huge business 16 billion dollar business
and it basically runs the entire
Internet so we went inside Intel so to
speak when into their Factory which is
called a fab and sort of watched watch
the magic happen and it really is kind
of magic I mean it's sort of amazing you
weren't allowed inside the cleanroom
itself but you got a sense of what it's
like the air incredibly pure a very
special kind of water they use what's it
like inside of there what are these
folks doing inside I mean it's
incredibly as you said incredibly clean
incredibly quiet I mean any vibration
would would sort of mess up the whole
process and would cost the company you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars if
one speck of dust
you know lands on a chip it's Dulles
yeah it's game over and they've lost
money and so you know it's just it's
just this very quiet almost like almost
felt like a cathedral uh we're just kind
of a weird feeling um and you know
there's just a lot of money at stake
yeah you talk about 2,000 steps of
lithography edging material application
then more etching how long does that
take and who gets trained to do that not
the developers surely know so it takes
about three months to go from the
silicon wafer buzzer that's crazy it is
eight three months three times longer
than like Boeing takes to assemble a
Dreamliner a car can get assembled in a
matter of days so that I mean this just
gives you a sense of how how sort of
risky it is people who do it are texts
basically they a couple years of college
of course there are also like PhDs who
are you know sitting there in funny
outfits like writing notes on special
cleanroom paper using special pens
making sure everything goes smoothly
we've heard about Moore's Law this this
idea that you get faster and faster and
faster faster as the years go on with
each different iteration what's the
biggest challenge that Intel another
chip makers face right now they've
gotten so fast they can do so much
processing can that law continuing
perpetuity right so the scuttlebutt
among you know chip geeks should be
proud yeah the chip crowd a very
distinct from the marijuana crowd is
that they is that Moore's law is ending
Intel would beg to differ
I mean basically what Intel says is like
we can keep this going for a really long
time the issue is can we do it cheaply
enough and that's what all of the energy
all of the research you know billions of
dollars a year are sort of pushing
towards this particular chip is the e5
what's it going to power and doesn't L
have a competitor in this space
so it's strangely Intel does not really
have a competitor the company has
depending on who you're talking to you
between 96 and 99 percent of the market
basically any data center you know
Amazon Facebook Google they're all
running versions of this chip and so
anything you do on the Internet if you
call an uber if you post a Facebook wall
post it's it's running through these
these data center chips it's a great
business and with huge margins they're
making like 50 percent margins more than
four thousand dollars is it going to
destroy jobs one word is it going to
destroy jobs I guess I guess in a sense
because you know as stuff gets automated
sure this is this is part of the you
know March of the digital revolution